вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми У
фокусі Європа Ми раді що ви приєдналися
до нас Україна протистоїть російському
вторгненню вже понад 450 днів на Донбасі
Українські війська схоже перейшли у
Контрнаступ
кадри звідти показують драматичний
перебіг цього конфлікту
на півдні України поблизу Херсона було
зруйновано велику дамбу в регіоні
контрольованому Росією
Київ звинувачує Москву той час як Кремль
заявляє що відповідальність несе Україна
під загрозою затоплення опинилися до 80
міст і сіл крім того Україна стверджує
що відвоювала частину окупованої
території на сході Донецької області що
Росія у свою чергу заперечує на даний
момент ці суперечливі твердження
неможливо незалежно перевірити
для солдатів на передовій кожен день
несе ризик поранені і смерті їх власно я
або їхніх товаришів
це досвід який залишає свій відбиток
особливо у наймолодших бійців таких як
20-річний український солдат його
ролійник який воює з перших днів
ми зустрілися з ним на передовій в
охопленій бойовими діями Донецькій
області
там В окопах ворог часто на відстані
витягнутої руки і Саме тут Єгор
сповнений рішучості продовжувати воювати
навіть попри те що він відновлюється
після важкого поранення
воювати В окопах важко і багато хто має
шарами війни його ролійнику вибухом
відірвало частину ноги і все ж він
повернувся до свого старого підрозділу
готується знову стати добою почуття
переповнюють його після повернення
тому що Ну воно прикольно той що душа
хоче той происходить ти ну це тут даже
наприклад свою злость там Ну щоб там не
посеред побратимів якось там і я ну
вийшов отстрілявся фу всьо так знаєте
спокойно розслабився
Єгор кадровий військовий він пішов
служити у 18 років спочатку в артилерію
а згодом на передову
[музика]
29 вересня це ми відбили позицію
це трофеї це все трофеї були
це ми передивлялися Трофей ночники
приціли там пістолети дивилися це
тільки-тільки захвачена була позиція
воно підбита техніка
ну трішечки знаєте емоції зашкалювали
просто отак от фу фу фу фу і там
автомати були оно оце все трофеї були
автомати вони прям кидали все своє то
есть
і саме цікаве воно просто в окопі лежить
ну це російський Освободитель
ця місія змінила його життя
одного разу Єгор і його команда захопили
російську позицію коли він пішов
оглядати місцевість то Наступив на мінус
його охопив страх що він може потрапити
в полон
зразу там собі першу медичну допомогу
яку зміг наложив і просто ліг і все
лежав а потім якось так мабуть злякався
і короче хотів застрелить себе але воно
так перебило мене якась така мисляті по
блін батьків ну тіпа Та нет тіпа це ну
всего лишь нога що це нагатій по-моему
коліно моє ходить зможуть іноді його
Кикоть були ці набрякає що його дуже
засмучує але Єгор каже що не вважає себе
інвалідом Він вчиться приймати свою нову
ситуацію
бачите мене татушка була зараз
то якраз обрізали по тату також
[сміх]
обрадила так в принципі Ну чуть-чуть
немає
в принципі
а Так получив поранення в цю ногу Тут у
мене тут один осколок тут був і ось тут
в кістку тряска попали
але щоб повернутися до роботи піхотинцем
Єгор мусить працювати і ногами Він
розповідає що лікарі не були задоволені
його рішенням повернутися на фронт і
його сім'я та дівчина були категорично
проти
батьки
ні Точно ну всі родичі можна сказати
казали що ні ні то есть там ну всі всі
проти абсолютно всі дівчина проти всі
повністю були проти але я кажу ні Я кажу
тіпа я буду йти кажу тіпа долг є в мене
перед державою потрібно її захищати Ну
тому що у нас в Україні якщо Ну чесно
вам так сказати ну ніхто не хоче Я вам
даже відпусті був коли ну друзі мої
колишні друзі той сидять вдома бухають
гуляють
його оружия повернувся на фронт але
воювати стало важче ніж раніше йому
доводиться швидко пересуватися по
багнюці та перелазити через перешкоди та
Ігор каже що товариші допомагають йому а
командири раді його повернення
добро то ми як боєць хоче в цьому Ми
ніколи не заперечимо так будемо брати на
примірні Єгора то тут вірте всі
пишаються що він молодець не впав духом
прекрасно себе почуває на позиції
проситься виходить все без Ну до нього
нема протест никаких Я у серпня знаю то
в боюсь прекрасний офіційних даних немає
але Єгор не єдиний боєць і зампотованої
кінцівкою який повернувся на фронт за
його словами Останні кілька місяців
змінили його більше злості появилась Ну
отомстити отомстити більше злості тому
що потрібно мстити і ну
потрібно повертатися як-не-як ну
особливо моя думка що після поранення
будь-якого потрібно повернутися показати
що ти більше можеш що ти це все
переживеш І що в тебе все вийде
після нашого від'їзду Єгор прийняв
запрошення до Норвегії на подальше
лікування незабаром Він планує
повернутися щоб далі давати відсіч
росіянам уже із новеньким протезом
із переміщенням лінії фронту в Україні
тиша настає там де ще кілька днів тому
було поле бою те що залишається позаду
це часто земля всіяна мінами бомбами що
не розірвалися та тілами загиблих
військових хоча достовірних цифр немає
згідно з оцінками багато десятків тисяч
солдатів українських і російських уже
втратили свої життя
забезпечення того щоб полегли не було
забуто це робота Михайла та його
спецпідрозділу вони виконують пошуково
евакуаційні місії для українських
військових аби загиблі могли бути гідно
поховані
поки повернувся у цю сільську частину
Харківської області це переважно
сільськогосподарські угіддя оточені
природними заповідниками але ще кілька
місяців тому тут точились за пеклі бої
дивився на те що тут відбувалося Це
просто страшно не знаю яка психіка всіх
людей залишилась Просто таких подій
десятки тисяч стіл загиблих лежать на
полях Битву вивести їх усіх неможливо
Михайло офіцер української армії знає
про це як ніхто інший він і його команда
мають нелегке завдання збирати загиблих
як українських так і російських
військових Вони теж для нас якби мають
свою цінність тому що ми вміємо їх на
своїх
вони роблять це для своїх українських
товаришів вони хочуть щоб усі хто
захищає свою батьківщину знали що
загиблі важливі що пам'ять про них
шанують тому хлопці дуже серйозно
ставляться до своєї роботи сьогодні вони
розшукують п'ятьох своїх побратимів
відпрацювавши всю інформацію з приводу
того звідки наступали і як наші хлопці
могли відходити на залишився єдиний
варіант де провірити де вони можуть де
вони можуть якби залишитись тому ми
зараз хочеш
вони ризикують власним
життєзамінована щоб зменшити ризик
пошуки частково проводить Пілот дрона
його робота у тому щоб
подивитись все розгледіти зверху щоб
побачити
в полях значить якісь
залишки рештки
ну або побачити якісь поверхневі міни
засоби мінування
він оглядає місцевість метр за метро і
попереджає товаришів про будь-які
загрози Вони працюють цілий день але
цього разу нічого не знаходять окрім
російського розвідувального безпілотника
деякого російського озброєння та великої
кількості боєприпасів п'ятеро
українських солдатів залишаються
зниклими безвісти
втомлені бійці повертаються до своїх
казарм все ще обдумуючи події дня
известность для нас на даний час дуже
дуже вважається
ну як би вам правильно сказати
дуже тяжко коли рідні не знають що зі
своїми
батьки це найгірше що може бути
увечері їм телефонує мер села гусарівка
що знаходиться неподалік на околиці села
знайшли тіла загиблих російських
солдатів
Наступного дня вони йдуть назустріч із
мером Юрій дорошенкова де їх до місця де
лежать ціла
це знайшли волонтерний по трасі хотіли
подивитися
і Так пройшли цей знайшли ці два труби
дати швидко беруться до роботи Спочатку
вони все детально документують
як завжди в будь-якій справі
найважливіші деталі щоб все зробити по
процедурі чітко яка узгоджена там мабуть
на рівні міжнародних які ми домовленості
ще законодавств і
дбати про те щоб Ну все зробити з
повагою
Ми вони мають справу з ворожими
солдатами для всіх тут важливо поважати
мертвих вони також повинні бути дуже
обережними ця місцевість теж була
інтенсивно замінована і деякі міни досі
не знешкоджені
чоловік їй кажуть що росіяни також часто
залишають міни пастки під цілами своїх
загиблих товаришів
тому вони спочатку прикріплюють мотузки
до тіл російських солдатів і обережно
пересувають їх
цього разу вибухових пристроїв немає
солдати готують мішки для тіл перед тим
як помістити тіло в мішок вони обшукують
в кишені документуючи все
бійці знаходять запальнички та цигарки
але не перший погляд нічого що могло б
ідентифікувати солдатів
але раптом Вони знаходяться ми те що
шукали
це ідентифікаційний жетон одного із
солдатів Пізніше вони знаходять
банківські картки усе це зачіпки які
допоможуть їм ідентифікувати загиблих ці
мішки є тіла не залишаться в Україні
надовго регулярно відбуваються обміни
загиблими між воюючими сторонами чоловік
і сподіваються що цих двох росіян
обміняють на двох їхніх полеглих
побратимів щоб їх могли гідно поховати
передусім для того щоб їхні сім'ї могли
знайти спокій
тим часом у Франції на вулиці виходять
протестувальники проти нещодавньої
пенсійної реформи основним її положенням
було підвищення пенсійного віку із 62 до
64 років вкрай непопулярна зміна
незважаючи на те що у більшості країн
Європи люди мають працювати набагато
довше але пенсіонерка міріамбас вважає
що реформи - Це єдиний спосіб покрити
зростаючий дефіцит пенсійного
забезпечення інші як Мелені молода
випускниця з Парижа кажуть що умови
праці у Франції так доволі складні І що
люди повинні мати можливість своєчасно
насолоджуватися виходом на пенсію
[музика]
після виходу на пенсію Міріам бас живе
на повну
[музика]
що понеділка після обіду колишня
Вчителька англійської мови ходить на
танці у Венеціанський ліс у Парижі
колишні мисливські угіддя вона каже її
дім насичені але спокійні
[музика]
важливо передавати досвід
Я беру з собою онуків У подорожі
на відпочинку Я вчу їх в'язати а також
танцювати
вона каже що любила свою роботу і не
зупинилася у 62 роки як більшість її
колег
Вона продовжувала викладати ще три роки
зараз багато молодих людей починають
працювати пізно Тому це нормально що їм
треба працювати до 604 або 65 років
Міріам бас не розуміє чому так багато
французів виступають проти пенсійної
реформи яка збільшує вік виходу на
пенсію до 64 років Вона зазначає що
літніх людей стає все більше А молодих
все менше держава повинна реагувати
Дехто з наших танцюристів таки виходив
на акції протесту проти реформ Але часто
у них просто інше ставлення до роботи а
дехто продовжує працювати навіть коли їм
далеко за 80
[музика]
Я працюю на волонтерських засадах
менеджером у компаніїх у стартапах
згідно з дослідженням престижного вищого
навчального закладу
більшість французів не відчувають
подібного задоволення від своєї роботи
Мелені вивчали історію мистецтв і
сподівалася стати куратором виставок але
не змогла знайти роботу
ми перед собором Паризької Богоматері
Мелені проводить екскурсії по Парижу для
туристів але вона не задоволена своєю
роботою
я почала працювати два місяці тому і
тепер немає ніякого соціального життя Я
працюю кожній вихідні на свята закінчує
пізно ввечері іноді о десятій вечора
прикро бо мені подобається моя професія
але я бачу що заради неї доводиться
дечим жертвувати обідню перерву Вона
проводить на самоті низ колегами вона
відчуває себе маленьким гвинтиком у
величезні туристичній машині Парижа
проте принаймні на папері французьке
законодавство дружнє до працівників
оскільки пропонує 35 годинний робочий
тиждень і щонайменше 5 тижнів щорічної
відпустки Міріам бас каже що багато
молодих людей не усвідомлюють наскільки
їм пощастило
Я думаю що ставлення до роботи змінилося
у мої часи робота була для мене способом
самореалізації і я була вчителькою тому
хотіла навчати ділитися знаннями зараз я
боюся що для молодих людей робота - це
більше про те щоб заробити багато грошей
Мелені справді хочу заробляти гроші але
вона прагне і визнання а не просто
відчувати себе номером
це район Дефенс діловий район Парижа усі
ці вежі офісні будівлі
одна статистика говорить що половина
працюючого населення Франції розчарована
занадто багато ієрархії і недостатньо
Свободи Мелені погоджуються
Я хочу любити свою роботу я хочу щоб
вона приносила мені задоволення якщо ти
не хочеш вставати вранці щоб піти на
роботу то нічого хорошого з цього не
вийде це контрпродуктивно
але Ця дівчина має заробляти на життя
тому вибір у неї невеликий вона мусить
працювати і оскільки вона мусить то
хотіла припинити працювати якомога
раніше тоді вона теж зможе насолодитися
життям на пенсії танцюючи у
венеціанському лісі
[музика]
У рамках загальнонаціональної компанії з
роззброєння в Сербії Було зібрано
близько 14 тисяч одиниць зброї ця
частина одномісячної амністії під час
якої громадяни могли здати свою не
зареєстровану зброю не боячись покарання
але дентомка каже що цього замало і
запізно
Сербія переповнена нелегальною
вогнепальною зброєю а уряд вже в заході
лише після того як 17 людей було вбито
під час двох масових стрілянин у травні
у той час як тисячі людей по всій Сербії
приєдналися до протестів проти
насильства із використанням зброї
володіння зброєю - це те що багато хто в
країні сприймає як належне
це процвітаючий бізнес
стрільба популярний вид спорту у Сербії
сьогоднішнім гостям видають снайперську
гвинтівку ця гвинтівка використовувалася
в Афганістані та Боснії кажуть оператори
з ноткою гордості позиція власника щодо
вогнепальної зброї чітка
вогнепальна зброя сама по собі нікого не
вбиває саме це ми хочемо донести до
людей
злочин чи вбивство можна скоїти
будь-якої зброї чи предметом усього є
дві сторони
нещодавно два злочини із застосуванням
вогнепальної зброї з сколихнули Сербію у
травні молодий чоловік убив вісьмох
людей У сусідньому селі у його сім'ї був
цілий арсенал зброї
Напередодні у белграді студент
застрелили вісьмох однокласників і
охоронця зі зброєю свого батька
після цих стрілянин на вулицю вийшли
десятки тисяч людей у тому числі і ідея
томка Діти якого навчалися у школі де
відбулася стрілянина система Держава всі
зазнали поразки у його очах він відчуває
що суспільство стає більш жорстоким
демонстранти хочуть щоб президент і уряд
пішли у відставку діти дає на томки
ледве вижили під час стрілянини у школі
він каже що ніколи не забуде пережити
остраху і скаржиться що їх залишили
справлятися із наслідками самостійно
сім'ї відчувають себе покинутими
Спочатку я відчуття шоку від цієї
ситуації набагато сильніше ніж ти може
зрозуміти політичними чи соціальному
сенсі
А потім нам довелося самим давати собі
радості і травмою
з цим страхом який ми всі пережили
Стрільцю у школі у Болграді було всього
13 років зброя на законних підставах
належала його батькові тижні потому люди
досі намагаються осмислити те що сталося
за даними дослідницького проекту small
Arm Survive Сербія посідає третє місце у
світі за рівнем володіння стрілецької
зброї за статистикою кожен третій серп
володіє зброєю часто нелегально хочеться
цифра і потроху зменшується сербське
збройове лобі говорить виключно про
легальну вогнепальну зброю
всім відсотків населення мають легальну
зброю а не 36 як виділяють іноземні
зміни
Це становить 12 одиниць зброї на сотню
жителів 10 разів менше ніж злучених
Штатах Америки
якщо цифри вірні а вони безумовно вірні
Ми одна з найменш озброєних країн Європи
після серії стрілянин уряд Сербії
закликав людей анонімно і безкарно здати
свою нелегальну зброю
тисячі людей вже зробили це крім того
легальна торгівля як зброю так і її
частинами була повністю заборонена на
два роки такий крок - це вже занадто
вважають оператори стрільбищ
сталося те чого не повинно було статися
Незалежно від того чи була зброя
легальної чи ні
що забороняти законний власникам зброї
робити те що раніше було легальним Це
занадто поспішний крок
де він каже що зброя це лише частина
проблеми Він говорить про загальну
бруталізацію сербського суспільства і
каже що про урядові канали такі як Pink
TV сприяють цьому на його думку Пінк ТВ
транслює контент найнижчого гатунку
суцільні лайки та бійки
форма насильства
воно не несе прямої віктимності але
створює відчуття атмосферу в якій ми
постійно знаходимося за крок до
вербального насильства
а згодом За крок до фізичного насильства
і вимагають закрити пін-tv тиск на владу
зростає уряд знає що настрої обертаються
проти нього
у травні автократичний президент Сербія
Олександр вучіч організував демонстрацію
на свою підтримку і звозив своїх
прихильників і з усієї країни до
болграда
[музика]
Олександр увучичу
Я підтримую свого земляка вучача за
сербів
уряд все що впевнено сидить у своїх
кріслах але в Сербії відчувається дух
змін
це те що я називаю карибським раєм Ми
зробимо все щоб зберегти його цей
райський острів належить до голландських
антильських островів а отже політично до
Нідерландів але заможна Європа головна
рушійна сила кліматичних змін які
становлять загрозу для острова бонайре
інженерка екологиня Джессіка Джонсон вже
давно на власному досвіді відчуває
драматичні наслідки глобального
потепління на землі Але у неї є план як
їх трохи пом'якшити
не можна більше втрачати часу а на
сьогодні це все із вами була програма У
фокусі Європа Дякуємо за перегляд
Бережіть себе і до наступної зустрічі
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]